c'est le tout premier
téléphone portable
[Musique]
et le premier appel téléphonique a été passé dans les
rues de New York, sur la 6e Avenue à New
York, près de l'hôtel Hilton
et je ne pensais vraiment pas à qui
j'allais appeler jusqu'au  à la dernière minute,
puis il m'est venu à l'esprit que je devrais
appeler mon homologue du
système Bell. J'ai dit à Joel, c'est Marty Cooper,
il a dit bonjour Marty
Joel, je vous parle sur un téléphone portable,
mais sur un vrai téléphone portable
personnel.
portable, il
y avait des colonies à l'autre bout
de la ligne, je pense que c'était génial contre
Chase,
vous
que le commerce des minéraux
ES
il y a du potentiel, je sais que cela
semble exagéré, mais je
la regarde partir d'ici une génération ou deux, nous
allons vaincre la maladie.  éliminer la
maladie
les gens qui ont un smartphone
les regardent trop, ils se laissent
prendre par le smartphone et je dois
vous dire que je suis dévasté quand je vois quelqu'un
traverser la rue et regarder son
téléphone portable et c'est un phénomène très courant,
il est hors de son  esprits
[Musique]
tout d'abord
et comme vous le savez